hello everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen ever
since this delightful show I'll call it
delightful ever since this show started
Doug Walker and Rob Walker have been
telling me that I need to watch a league
of their own I've been planning on doing
it for this channel for a very long time
but I never wanted to watch it without
them because they were so pumped about
the film so we finally got a date
together and we watched it all together
a couple days ago I'm ready to go I've
already seen it
this is just a fun little intro I also
will be doing predictions for this one
you can only really predict tears of joy
and happiness for women everywhere let's
go
[Music]
I'm not crying you're crying shut up
there's no crying in baseball
Doug and Rob we're like I really hope we
haven't overhyped this film because
legitimately they have been talking
about it since day one of Tamra's never
seen have you seen a league of their own
you've got to see it they reference it
all the time and now I get those
references I just have this awesome
movie now that I know about for like
women's empowerment I've a new cosplay I
want to do Madonna obviously I loved her
weirdly I was like it's Madonna and
actress and Doug was like no but she's
good in this this pink mint is emit my
friends let me use for our softball team
chat Steadman's where I played catcher
because I'm awful watching this group of
women change everything for women
forever that's so cool it's like when I
watched glow and I didn't know that the
gorgeous ladies of wrestling was a thing
and I watched that series which was just
amazing and then I went and watched the
documentary on the actual real ladies
and it was just like well that's cool
there was one moment where a black woman
picked up the ball of threw it and that
was the kind of all you got there was it
was only white women on the team and I
imagine that that was just that was just
the time unfortunately
thank God they put in that that point
though because if there was just like no
african-american ladies that would have
been a real bummer for
I was talking with all the guys and
apparently there is a deleted scene that
Barney saw where Tom Hanks character
kisses Geena Davis's character and they
cut it out and that was maybe the best
decision they made for the entire film
it would have changed everything
completely if there was they had a
chemistry together and it's because of
their love of baseballs because she was
kind of hard and tough and you know they
they they went well together but there
didn't need to be a kissing scene he
really really loved her husband and she
was an awesome guy and Tom Hanks was
still figuring it out but you know they
didn't need to be together
it would have totally changed the tone
of the film and watching it through
knowing that the whole time was just I
was just incredibly relieved didn't they
they didn't have that set in stone
romantic vibe going on they had there
was enough of that just unspoken that
they like admired each other whether
that was romantic or not it was there so
we're just nice to not have the like
actual let's kiss on three so great that
that was coming about dad was like
there's really not anything that you
could cut out from this movie it all
really works and makes sense and yes
yeah totally there's like a bunch of
these long sports montages that I let me
tell ya not a giant fan of in films and
they were so wonderful in this I just
loved everything was it just spaced out
really well it felt good it didn't feel
at all dragging or long I feel like the
only word you can use to describe this
film is delightful it's just a goddamn
delight Tom Hanks let's be real national
treasure great guy
hilarious talented dramatic acts his
pants off and everything he's in this
role was perfect for him he was so not
polished Tom Hanks which I really love
polished Tom Hanks but does that make
sense he was he was still a little rough
around the edges he's very young this
was made in 1992
I believe and he was still kind of like
I feel like you and those like goofy
goofy parts getting like goofy bits and
and he did it so well he was such a jury
I loved it
again another great example of somebody
taking an unlikable character and just
making him so entertaining
that was how I felt about the guy in
glow who had the same kind of role in
that Sammy or Sam Disney Marc Maron
Marc Maron some of the Lions in this
film were so good so funny so heartfelt
so perfect there's no crying in baseball
it's supposed to be hard if it wasn't
hard everyone would do it oh my god Dave
hooch I know my girly so pretty as these
girls but that's my fault I raised her
like a boy I didn't know any better she
loves to play don't make my little girl
suffer because I raised I messed up
raising her please I just started crying
then and there like pretty much the
beginning of the film when they're
recruiting ladies also she was just my
very favorite character okay also one
thing real fast can we talk about how GD
delightful Jon Lovitz is in this movie I
don't know that I've ever laughed harder
at Jon Lovitz I think I look at him as
one of those actors who were like trying
too hard and that's somebody who does
that
III understand I understand John but
whoa he was so funny in this everything
he said was hilarious would you shut up
just every up no one was awkward in
their line delivery
no one was bad in their roles everyone
was just good like they just rocked it
feel like growing up the only baseball
movie that I ever saw was angels in the
outfield
I love that film and I will fight you if
you don't I won't so not not many
baseball movies I wasn't really a
baseball movie enthusiast but this was
such a cool story of how women during
the war took over because there were no
men to play crushed it did what they had
to do to get ahead
dottie with her splits that was amazing
loved that part and then at the end when
they get into the Hall of Fame just you
know tears and emotion also our friend
Matt was there and he he was saying like
I saw this when I was too young like six
or something
that's true it's definitely a you get
you appreciated as you get older and
tell get robbed we're like we didn't
hike this but no I don't think we
overhyped it because it's it's really
good it is it's just it's it's so good
it's a movie I would watch it again
right now I loved also watching them
watch it and seeing like the lines that
really got to them and they've seen it
before and they was it's so fun when you
you get to experience a movie with
someone that they really love or it's
treacherous if you don't like it that's
that compete bad thing as well kind of
funny because I know a lot of people
watch this series because they want to
relive that that first time kind of
experience but it was kind of in a
different way fun to watch them relive
it again that was awesome Rosie
O'Donnell guns Creed and Malcolm what to
be he's like she did she I mean it was
made in 92 so like so long ago 20
huh 25:25 that was amazing
which is good because next week I'm
pretty sure I'm going to watch Howard
the Duck I've never seen Howard the Duck
and after let me be clear I know what
Howard the Duck is I know it's this
awful movie that's just really missed
its mark crazy nutso film and when
guardians of the galaxy kind of shouted
out words and junk it's like I mean I've
not seen it no no plans to I was talking
about that one who dug and Robin them at
the last convention and they were like
no you have to do this perfect Duke that
we're Timbers never seen so you know
there's a bus no I really truly am
excited to see it I think it's gonna be
a fun bad hopefully god I hope it's a
fun bad y'all probably want to know how
this purple hair sounds when I flip it
right so different right thank you so
much for watching a go check out next
week for Howard the Duck and I'll see
y'all
very soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you